former the Earth's while president and
great unindicted co-conspirator I'm not
sure exactly that part knee the reason I
find myself I don't learned this couple
years ago and you can see it on YouTube
Cavett decides to get Nixon decides to
screw cam it
I think it's titled from the Nixon tapes
there he and Halderman hauled him and
his four young folks this was one of
Richard Nixon's assistants henchmen and
lickspittles said we got to get Cabot
you know who is this cat what is Cavett
and Haldeman says well he's the worst
he's always loading the show where the
Nixon cuts in with but what are we gonna
do anyway it contains the immortal line
by the chief executive how can we screw
him and Nixon's inimitable delivery well
we're working on that I think it's out
in partly it had to do with the fact
that I testified that John Lennon should
not be deported from the US although
Richard Nixon's administration and
Richard Nixon wanted to that's that
again was Haldeman there's a tape tape
somewhere where Haldeman says you know
this Lennon he could sway an election
and that was an enough for a tricky dick
to hear it's a shame about Nixon I wrote
two really good blogs about him on my
New York Times online blogs that cabin
NY Times I just read them and they're
better than I thought when I wrote them
one of them is very funny and very
embarrassing at the same time but I
mentioned in them that the the the shame
about Nixon is that he was certainly the
most intelligent president we had had in
a long time and his remarkable brains
and legal grasp and intelligence were so
tragically wasted by his
criminal personality